FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
68 of the Weekly Google
Cloud platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing well, Francesc.
It's all over.
Next is over.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Listen to this--
silence.
MARK MANDEL: Silence, I know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No background
music, no background noise.
We're back to our studio.
Cloud Next is over.
It was amazing,
But we're also very
happy it's over because
that was pretty intense.
MARK MANDEL: It
was pretty intense,
but it was really cool.
I had an amazing time, and
I think a lot of people
did as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was
amazing meeting so many people.
Thanks to every single
one of the people that
came by, and took pictures,
and just like wave at us,
or came in, said hi, asked
questions, and all that stuff.
If you have pictures with any
of us or whatever, the podcast,
send it to us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Send it
all to your GC podcast
or-- we'll repeat all of
these things at the end.
But yeah.
Send them to us.
We'd love to have a little bit
of a photo album remembering
the memories.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that would be nice.
And thanks to
everyone who sent me
photos of dogs for my birthday.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Happy birthday.
MARK MANDEL: That was nice.
I appreciated that.
All right, cool.
Why don't we get started?
So we've got our
interview today,
which is with William
Bonnell from The Home Depot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The Home Depot.
Yeah, indeed.
MARK MANDEL: We're going
to talk about SRE stuff
at The Home Depot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We interviewed him
during Cloud Next.
So you'll hear some of
that beautiful background
that you may be used to it now.
But it was an amazing interview.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it really was.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
really, really enjoyed it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then at the end,
we'll have the
question of the week.
We record that question
during Cloud Next,
but we will give you
the answer today.
But before that, we will
start with our cool things
of the week.
And this time, we have 101
cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, cool things.
Yeah, I think that's good.
So I don't think we can
go through them all quite
clearly for time constraints.
But there is a blog post, 100
announcements from Google Cloud
Next, 2017, from acquisitions,
partnerships, new products,
releases.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
really like Identity
of Where Proxy because
it's the thing that we've
been using internally
for quite a while,
and it just makes things easier.
So if you're a
developer and need
to make sure that some
services are accessible only
to your employees
or specific people,
but you don't want to handle
authentication by yourself,
go check it out.
It is pretty cool.
But there's so much stuff.
MARK MANDEL: So much stuff.
If you had to pick--
I'd say you've got one.
Say, pick another one.
What's another exciting one?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, Community Site.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I
was going to do that.
You said that one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cloudgoogle.com/community is
beta.
And basically, it allows you
to have the communication that
is editable, well, kind of.
Basically, you can sample
request them fix it.
So that is very, very nice,
very happy about that one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's
going to be great for community
people to come in, and help
us with our documentation,
or help with
tutorials and samples.
I'm super excited about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, so many.
I'm going with Postgres.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I feel like
I have to go Postgres.
I feel like we should
give that some love.
There have been
so many people who
have been clamoring for
Postgres for so long.
And I'm so happy
for it finally to be
with us that I am super,
super, super happy about that.
And for a second one, second
one, I like 64-core machines.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Give
me all the CPU.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Now you can
create a 64-core machines
with I don't know
how many terabytes
of-- not terabytes of
RAM, or is it terabytes?
MARK MANDEL: Where are we?
Have doubled the
number of virtual CPUs
you can run in an
instance from 32 to 64
and up to 416 gigabytes
of memory per instance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so
it's not terabytes yet.
But we're not getting--
MARK MANDEL: Half way way,
close to half way there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
you can also add eight CPUs,
and you have the most powerful
machine you can imagine.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
why even bother
buying a machine at home.
Just use that constantly.
All right, so I think
there's definitely
cool things that way.
There's one other cool thing
I want to mention really
quickly because it came
out just before Next,
and I think it got
buried a little.
So there's a new issue track
out for Google Cloud platform.
And this is the one centralized
tracker, which is super cool.
So you can go to
issuetracker.google.com,
and you can go there
and search through it
for any public issues for,
basically, any of our products,
which is super sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not only Google
Cloud platform, but actually,
just Google.
So you'll see bug
for everything.
Basically, the whole
point here is not as much
for you to submit more
bugs, but to also track
what we're working on,
and what are the things
we're trying to fix,
and stuff like that.
So it's a very good
point to go and see it.
MARK MANDEL: And also, it's just
a discoverability thing, right?
Before, you had to be like,
which product am I looking at?
Which bug tracker
is it working on?
I need to go find it.
Now, there's just one
place for you to go.
If you had to submit a
bug or check on a bug,
this is the one
place you can do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is definitely nice.
I did not know
that this existed,
and I used it yesterday.
I was actually
tracking an issue.
So there you go.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we go have
a chat with our friend
William from The Home Depot?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: I'm super excited
to have William Bonnell here
joining us on the [INAUDIBLE]
floor at Cloud Next.
He is Senior Director of
Site Reliability Engineering
at Home Depot.
William, how are
you doing today?
WILLIAM BONNELL: I'm doing well.
I'm really excited to be here.
I actually been looking
forward to talking to you guys
the whole time I've been here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Same for us.
It's been amazing to see
Home Depot on the keynote,
on the floor.
It's been everywhere.
And it's very exciting to be
able to have you to tell us
a little bit about
what you're actually
doing at Home Depot
with a SREs, and CREs,
and all the cloud stuff.
So--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
but before we do that,
you want to tell us
a little about what
you do at Home Depot,
what's your role there,
and what does that involve?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Sure.
So I'm responsible for the
reliability engineering
strategy The Home Depot.
So that's the broad across
the entire enterprise.
My specific responsibilities
in terms of teams that I manage
are our e-commerce-- so
that's the customer facing
the e-commerce part
of the business--
and then our back end order
management, so everything
we're doing with
order management.
We're talking
millions of customers
per day come to the website.
And we're processing millions
of transactions and orders
on the back end every day.
So I'm looking after
that every day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So two things-- first one is I
noticed that we say Home Depot,
and you say it the Home Depot.
What is the correct
way of saying this?
MARK MANDEL: The Home Depot is--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The Home Depot--
MARK MANDEL: Got it,
WILLIAM BONNELL: We actually
call ourselves THD, acronym--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is like the internet.
MARK MANDEL: Got it, yeah.
WILLIAM BONNELL: We're
the Ohio State University.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
second question is--
what does your stack look like?
What are-- like
you said, did you
process a bunch
of events per day?
How do you process those?
Are you on premise?
Are you on the Cloud?
WILLIAM BONNELL:
Well, right now, we're
in the middle of a hybrid.
We have on-premises,
and we have cloud.
We've actually been working
with Google for about two years
to move our e-commerce platform
to the Google Cloud platform.
So we're a little bit
in a hybrid today.
We actually talked about that.
We had a couple of
speaking sessions
this conference
where we actually
talked about that architecture.
So we're about 75% into the
Google Cloud platform now,
and we're finishing
it up this year.
MARK MANDEL: So that's
really interesting.
So can we get some
history there?
It sounds like you were
originally on-prem,
and then at some point, you
made the decision to shift.
What happened there?
Why did you make that decision?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Sure.
So we had a classic
legacy e-commerce platform
that we've been
running for many years.
And that really got to the
point where it served us well
for many years.
But it got to the point
where it was constraining us.
It was constraining us both
from infrastructure scalability
standpoint-- very hard
to kind of scale it out.
Plus, we had a big,
monolithic database
that was almost
impossible to scale out
at our level of scale.
Imagine running a $5
plus billion website
on pretty much a
single database.
And of course, you
can scale that up,
and you can do
some things there.
But that was constraining us.
But in addition to that,
the velocity of our business
was constrained.
The throughput of being able
to deploy constant innovation
to it was constrained with the
type of platform we were on.
First and foremost,
we were looking
for building a custom
platform that will allow
us to innovate much faster.
We had gotten to the point
where the old platform where
we could deploy weekly, that
was as good as we could do
was a weekly deploy.
MARK MANDEL: That
was pretty good.
WILLIAM BONNELL: And we
wanted to get the point where
actually-- and we're
doing that now.
We're deploying
many times a day,
many different things every day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So yeah.
You gave us a little bit
of the reasons why you
decided to move to the cloud.
How did you move to the cloud?
WILLIAM BONNELL: So
we moved to the cloud,
chipping away one
piece at a time.
Even before we started
working with Google,
we actually started
pulling out some
of the pieces of the
e-commerce platform
into a microservices-like
architecture.
So we might pull out something
like the product information
page on the site, or it could
be the promotions engine,
things like that.
We started pulling
some of those pieces
out into our
on-premise environment,
even before we
started with Google.
And then we continue
with that strategy.
So we say one of the first
things we launched into Google
was our store finder.
So that thing about store finder
is a service, self-contained.
We can build a development
team around it.
They can innovate and push
as often as they want,
and they don't have
to go coordinate
with the team that's doing
the cart in our old platform.
The cart team and
the store finder team
had to push their
changes together.
Didn't really make a
whole lot of sense,
but that's the way our
deployment architecture worked.
MARK MANDEL: So actually, we
get this question all the time
when people like,
I had this thing,
and I want to move
it to the cloud.
How did you choose which
pieces to move when,
or what part to take out?
Was there a safety
consideration,
or you wanted to
get a new feature?
How did you make
those decisions?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah,
that's kind of challenging.
It really depends on--
there's a number
of factors there.
One of the things
that we've been
doing throughout
this migration--
and it's taken us the
last couple of years--
is still using our on-prem
e-commerce platform
as the nucleus.
So that's the nucleus.
And as we're pulling
pieces out, we're
still running things
through that central hub,
and so that I can make calls
out to services, for example,
that we may launch into
the Google Cloud platform.
So we've just been
doing that piecemeal.
The other thing
that we did was we
did some of the things that
may be a little easier, less
transactional initially.
I mentioned the store finder.
That's something that's
a service that doesn't
have a transactional nature.
It's more of a read
only type of service.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I think
that is worth mentioning.
There's a book that
I've been reading about,
specifically, this topic.
The question you asked,
there's a whole book on it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'm
sure there's more than one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's a book.
I think it's really good.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Well,
there's a microservices book,
which is the O'Reilly book.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Exactly, by Sam Newman.
That's exactly what I had had.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is a very good book,
exactly covering those topics.
So if anyone in the audience
is curious about it,
I definitely recommend it.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah.
And that's actually a book--
I know specifically,
it was one that we
had talked a lot
about internally, even
before we went on this journey.
There's another one also, and
the name is slipping my mind.
But it's an O'Reilly book--
just came out recently.
It was written by
an SRE at Uber.
But it's about running
microservices, operating
microservices in production.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Since we're talking
about books, have
you read the SRE book,
the Google SRE book?
What do you think about it?
WILLIAM BONNELL:
Yeah, most definitely
read the Google SRE book--
excellent book, great theme.
I really like the approach
where they chose real SREs
within Google to
actually write chapters
that they're experts in.
That really worked well.
I've read the book--
actually, have
a Ben Trainer-signed
copy of the book, which
I'm very excited about.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is pretty fancy.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I'm curious though.
You're director of
SRE at The Home Depot.
WILLIAM BONNELL: The Home Depot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The Home Depot.
MARK MANDEL: Do you see
any major differences
in terms of how
you do SRE at THD,
or versus what you've seen, at
least externally from Google?
How's that set up for you?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yep.
Well, I'll mention it really
isn't external from Google
in the sense that
we've been very engaged
with Google's Customer
Reliability Engineering Team.
We've been heavily
engaged with them.
And so they've helped inform us
on Google's way of doing SRE.
A couple of things I
would mention there is,
the historical context
that The Home Depot,
and our e-commerce team is--
we historically had more of what
you might call web engineering
or web operations
team, where we're
managing the infrastructure.
It's more manual, We do have
some automation in there.
But the infrastructure
itself is not manual,
and the provisioning
is much harder.
So as we evolved
into the SRE model,
we did that at the same time as
we migrated to the Google Cloud
platform.
And the big difference
there is we're
interacting with the
infrastructure everything,
firewall, compute, storage.
You name it, we're interacting
with it through APIs,
and we're provisioning
things automatically.
So we're no longer logging into
servers and making changes.
We're doing everything
in an automated way.
That's been really
important to us.
MARK MANDEL: No longer
picking up racks of servers
and physical
firewalls and stuff?
WILLIAM BONNELL: No, not at all.
In fact, that's a
distant memory for us.
And it's just something
we don't even think about.
So that's a force
multiplier for us.
So rather than spending those
calories on that type of work,
we're spending the calories
on automating our platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is great.
So you mentioned that
you know SRE culture too
because you were
interacting with CRE?
Could you tell us more
about your experience
interacting with them?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Sure,
so Dave Renson, who
invented the idea of CRE,
created the idea of CRE
within Google--
and Luke Stone approached me
in probably the summertime
last year with this idea.
And this idea was bringing
SRE principles to customers,
and wondered if
I'd be interested.
And before they could finish
asking me the question,
I said yes.
I would definitely be
interested in that.
And one of the things I
think a lot about when
I'm thinking about public
cloud, and I'm thinking
about enterprise is
considering public cloud,
there's a couple of
big considerations
for an enterprise.
One of them is, of
course, going to be cost.
And so thinking about how
to manage that properly
in the cloud is important.
But the second one
is reliability,
because if you
have an enterprise,
and they're a little nervous
about going to the cloud,
and they start pushing
mission-critical workloads
out there, and they
fail, regardless
of whether it's the cloud
provider's fault or not,
they're going to
potentially pull back.
And so the idea of
CRE is to, especially
for very large customers,
is to help them build out
the practices of reliability
so that they're actually
successful when they
deploy their workloads out
to the cloud.
It's not trivial.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you've
been working with CRE
for quite a while, I imagine.
Is there any moment that you
think it as fun or interesting
that you could share?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Well,
there's actually probably
a lot of moments.
First of all, I'll say the
team, AJ, and Matt Brown,
Adrian Hilton, Luke Stone, Dave
Renson, this really crack team
of--
I mean, this is some
really talented SREs.
And then one of topics
that we explored,
even in the happy hour with them
with the bends the other day
was the software engineer
versus reliability engineer.
How do you get the talent into
reliability engineering teams?
It's clear that Google hires
the best talent in the world
into their SRE teams.
And so these guys
definitely demonstrated
a very deep understanding of how
to run large-scale production
systems.
And so the team was really,
really, really insightful.
They did googly
things, SRE things,
like application
reliability reviews,
and they did deep dive.
Actually, one of
the things we talked
about in the very beginning
of the conversation
with Dave and Luke
was, if they were
going to do this, and
share fate with us,
and be in our Black
Friday war room,
they wanted us to remediate
any high-risk items they found.
So we agreed to that,
and we did that.
MARK MANDEL: So actually, you
bring up an interesting point.
So I used to do a lot
of e-commerce stuff.
Black Friday is a very big
time for a lot of people
who do e-commerce stuff.
How was your Black Friday?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah.
No, our Black Friday was great.
And, in fact, Paul Gaffney,
our SVP of development,
mentioned that in the keynote,
that we actually had--
this last Black Friday
we had half of our site
in on-prem and half of our
site on Google Cloud platform--
so a lot of risk even there,
you think about not even
just in the Google
Cloud platform,
but the interconnectivity
and so forth
with our on-premise platform.
And so we talked a little bit
about that in the keynote.
But just to cut to the chase,
it was a very successful Black
Friday, 100% availability,
performance was rock solid,
and the Google CRE team
was right there with us.
They were right there in
a virtual war room with us
the whole time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
congratulations on that.
I know it's not easy, so--
WILLIAM BONNELL: No.
Nope, it's not.
And it's getting
harder and harder.
With the type of architecture,
the microservices architecture,
and the amount of change we have
is getting harder and harder
every year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So I'm curious about
how you handle that
Black Friday, meaning what
is the stack behind it?
Are you running
on compute engine?
What are you doing?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah.
One thing I'll mention
is probably interesting--
and it actually came up
in my talk on Wednesday--
is we didn't have to provision
servers six months in advance
only to have them sit around
for the remainder of the year.
So we, actually, at
CRE's recommendation,
we actually
increased our quotas,
and actually bumped up
our capacity about a week
before Black Friday
just in case.
If we lost a region, we
wouldn't have any blips there.
And then after we got
through Cyber Monday,
we just provisioned
that back down.
So right there, the
power of the cloud,
the elasticity of
the cloud right
then and there is
a huge deal for us.
In terms of platform-- so
we've been working with Google
for about two years now.
So some of the
choices we made were
architecturally the right choice
at the time two years ago.
So we're very much
on compute engine.
We're not running in
containers at this point,
but that's mostly just because
it wasn't mature at the time
when we started doing this.
MARK MANDEL: Managed
instance groups?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Oh, yeah.
We're definitely using
managed instance groups.
We're running out
of multiple regions.
In each region, we
have multiple zones.
We actually took
this opportunity
when we were building
our platform.
We actually took the
opportunity from the ground up
to build every
application hot hot.
So everything we
have is hot hot.
We actually just did a--
and I call it a DR test.
So it doesn't feel
like a DR test anymore.
But we just recently
did a DR test
where we basically just shut all
the traffic off to the US East
just to see how
that would behave.
And all of our workloads
were on hot hot.
So it was a nonevent for us.
That's pretty huge for us.
MARK MANDEL: So you
use the term hot hot.
For those people
who aren't familiar,
what do you mean by that?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Right,
so active active--
you have an application.
In the easiest case,
where you don't have a--
it's not transactional.
That's just deploying it
to multiple-- in my case,
it would be multiple
data centers,
multiple regions, ideally.
In the case where you have
a transactional system,
you have the data.
You have your back end data
that's actually replicated
across those regions.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And you were also
talking about before you
were hitting certain scale
limits with your database.
Have you actually started moving
data into Google Cloud as well,
and splitting that
out per service?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Oh,
yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
So every microservice,
if they need a database,
they have a database.
We generally-- not every service
we have needs a database.
Sometimes it could
be a search platform,
those sorts of things.
But everyone that
needs a database-- that
was a big principle for us,
because in the old world
everything ran against
the same database,
and that created
some constraints.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
talk about databases.
Can you talk a little bit about
how do you store your data?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Sure.
So in our case, our primary
database is Casandra.
We actually decided to
self-manage our own database.
That's something--
we're actually
looking at the database
platforms that are available,
Cloud SQL, Cloud
Datastore, even Spanner.
Spanner is actually
very exciting.
If you think about--
we're a top 10
internet retailer.
And you think about our cart
service and check-out service.
Something like Spanner
would be very attractive.
Of course, that's
just in beta now.
It wasn't even
something we knew about
other than the white paper,
and CockroachDB, and so forth.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Basically,
it came out last week.
So it's normal.
You have not been
[INAUDIBLE] yet.
WILLIAM BONNELL: So we decided
to manage our own Casandra.
And that has been--
Casandra, being
eventually consistent,
you might say, hey, how do
you run transactional things
in the old world?
You might expect asset
type of transactions.
But what we found is
that the Google network
is so reliable, and so fast,
that even though Cassandra
is eventually consistent, it
updates almost instantaneously.
So we see very few problems with
the eventually consistent model
there.
MARK MANDEL: And I know Francesc
is going to ask this question,
so I'm going to jump in on it.
What languages do
you develop with?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah, not Go.
Sorry, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
OK, well, thank you
so much for taking your time.
WILLIAM BONNELL: We actually
have one of our pieces
that you guys might
be interested--
I can tell you a
little bit about that.
But Java is our
primary platform.
That's primarily because
we're a large enterprise,
and at most enterprise you
would talk to, like Home Depot,
it's probably going to be Java.
Maybe you'd find
dot net as well.
But those are going to be your
primary programming languages.
And that was easier
for us to migrate to.
We are, though, opening up the
ability for development teams
to use other
development platforms.
But that's our primary one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And you mentioned
you have a bunch of
different microservices.
How do you communicate
across them?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah,
so we communicate.
Actually, we communicate-- so
internal load balancer was not
available when we decided
to go into Google.
And so we actually
create a mechanism.
And we've actually talked
to some other companies,
did similar sort of things.
We used Console for
service discovery.
And so we built
that into our-- so
if one service wants to call
another, we go through Console,
basically look up the service,
and then make a direct call
to it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And RPC-wise, are
you using something
really similar to gRPC?
Did you build your own thing?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah, we're
just using RESTful APIs.
GRPC is something
we're looking at again.
Availability of these
things hasn't been there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's also pretty new.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I'm also curious.
We were talking about
that split between going
from monolithic on-prem,
and then your microservices.
How has that impacted
your CI/CD, your testing
infrastructure, which
probably also impacts
your liability, et
cetera, et cetera?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Oh, yeah.
It's like firehose.
There's constant changes.
That's a good thing.
We're doing much
smaller changes,
and we have problems with them.
We also built-- if you want to
talk about leveraging multiple
zones, and multiple regions,
and leveraging Cloud Deployment
Manager for doing those deploys,
and being able to roll them
out, and drain traffic
as we need to--
so when we have
problems, the problems
are much smaller than
they were before.
If we're doing a big, weekly
release, and we had a problem,
you'd feel it a lot more.
And now, we're able
to do the changes.
Yeah.
You might have a little problem.
So we're seeing that teams are--
also, this is something
we're encouraging.
And remember, I'm the
ops guy, if you will.
So I might be the last
person you would expect.
But we're encouraging
teams to spend less time,
and not no time, but
less time on testing,
and performance testing in
the lower lifecycle and a test
environment just because a lot
of time that's just simulated.
Until you actually
get into production,
get some traffic on it, get
some real customer traffic,
you don't really know
what you're going to get.
MARK MANDEL: And I'm guessing
then your rollback system
is very simple and automated.
So if you put
something out there,
maybe you put 10% traffic
on it, see how it does,
and you can always roll it back.
WILLIAM BONNELL: That's right.
That's been key to
everything we're
doing from the very
beginning, is make sure
all those are
completely automated.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
moving a little bit away
from all the tech stuff, even
though it's super interesting,
you were in the keynote.
Tell us a little bit about it.
What was the message?
What happened up there?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Sure, so
I wasn't in the keynote.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I mean The Home Depot.
MARK MANDEL: The Home Depot.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah,
so Paul Gaffney spoke.
And one of the things
he talked about was--
mentioned the Black Friday.
That was a big deal for us.
And for him to talk about
that-- as a retailer,
you said you're in e-commerce
and how important that is--
to put the trust
in Google, to be
able to run those kind of
workloads, its volumes.
And, really, we wanted to
highlight that for the world
and say, hey, this is a platform
that we're finding highly
reliable, excellent
performance, and then
with the CRE engagement
on how to operate
these things at scale.
That was the message we wanted
to convey in the keynote.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And on top of that, there
were also two sessions.
Do you remember the names?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Sure.
So the session I did,
I did with Luke Stone,
who's on the CRE team, and
Mahesh from the network SRE
team.
It was called 24/7 Resiliency.
So we looked at--
it was Luke's idea.
He did a great job
facilitating it.
And then the idea
was thinking about--
and actually, this is actually
a really important principle--
is turtles all the way down.
You've got the network,
the network SRE team.
They run the network.
The cloud team
doesn't really have
to know a whole lot about what
the network team is doing,
provided the network team
is not causing any issues.
And then the cloud,
the cloud SRE team
is providing service to us.
We don't really have
to know a whole lot.
We don't care when you're
patching load balancers,
and you're patching servers,
and those sorts of things.
We don't really care about that.
We don't need to
know about that.
And then you come to our
layer, the application,
and we're running our
application, and our SRE team.
And so it's really everybody
playing their position,
and doing it well.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And I believe you also had a
microservices talk as well?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah, we
had a microservices talk.
On the third day, Robbie
[INAUDIBLE] talked with--
and those names
just slipped my mind
because it wasn't my session.
But we talked about-- the
Googlers talked about security
and load balancing.
And then we reviewed
our microservices,
also our lessons learned.
And it was interesting because
those were the sessions
your customers liked.
Because I could see people like
taking pictures of the screen,
the lessons learned one.
I could see people
taking pictures
of that, because
that's what really
resonates with other people
thinking about using Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And for all
the people that we're not there,
were not able to take
pictures of the screen,
all of those talks
were recorded.
And by the time this
episode comes out,
they will be already online.
So we'll have links to the
videos on the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
All right, cool.
So we're running out of
time just a little bit.
Is there anything else you
want to highlight, or plug,
or anything we haven't
talked about yet that you
think is really interesting?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Well, we
talked a little bit about that
prior to this.
But the question around
DevOps versus SRE,
and what's the difference,
at least from my perspective.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, sure.
WILLIAM BONNELL: And so DevOp--
and we actually had
something called
DevOps within The Home Depot.
But DevOps, and most
companies I've talked to,
seems to be much
more CI/CD, build
pipeline, automation-related,
and automating
all those things, and the
testing and deployment
of your application.
Site reliability
engineering, with the way
we've implemented it, also with
our relationship with Google,
is much more around the
production environment,
and automating and
engineering the production
environment for high
availability, performance, et
cetera.
So that's how we've implemented
it at The Home Depot.
I will say-- I think you
asked the question earlier.
Our level of-- everybody
we hire into our team,
which by the way, we're hiring.
Home Depot is hiring.
MARK MANDEL: Good to know.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Everybody
we hire into our team
is going to have some
kind of automation
background, generally Python.
Other programming languages are
fine because we're interacting
with the Google APIs.
But our level of
software engineering,
I think comparable to Google
is probably not quite there.
We want to grow it over time.
We think about Google.
They say, hey, 50% of their time
is actually building software.
We're not quite
there yet, but that's
something we're interested
in marching toward.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Amazing.
So for people that
might have companies
not maybe as big
as The Home Depot,
but that are right
now on-premises
and they're considering
moving to the cloud,
what would be your
piece of advice?
WILLIAM BONNELL:
So I would say one,
regardless of where you
host, whether it's on a cloud
that you have in
your data center,
whether it's Google Cloud
platform, or a competitor,
you need to build your
application cloud native,
right--
12-factor app, and
all the things that
go into building your
application in that way.
You need to build
it in smaller pieces
so you can do independent
development and deploy so you
can get the business velocity.
That would be the
number one thing.
But the second thing
I would mention,
especially when you're
building applications at scale,
is the operational side of it.
I think don't underestimate
the complexity of trying
to run all-- especially
if you embrace
a microservices architecture,
don't underestimate
the complexity of running
all those pieces at four
nines of availability.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, William, thank you so
much for taking time, and coming
and hanging out
here at Cloud Next.
We really appreciate
you just talking to us.
It was really super fascinating.
WILLIAM BONNELL: My pleasure.
I was really excited
about doing it.
I appreciate you guys
giving me the opportunity.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you very much.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So thanks again,
William, for taking the
time out of his, I'm sure,
busy Cloud Next
schedule to talk to us
for such an interesting topic.
SRE is one of the favorite
topics, other than Kubernetes,
maybe, in the podcast.
And it is always good to
see how all the people
outside of Google are doing it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and it was also
great to hear about his
experiences with CRE as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah, very, very cool.
OK, so I guess it's time to go
with a question of the week--
is as an experiment, we actually
have someone asking a question.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we
have our friend AJ.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so let's
listen to that question.
AJ: Yeah, so Cloud
Spanner looks fantastic,
and I'm really
excited to try it out.
I'm wondering if for a
business that's currently
using something,
maybe like MySQL,
or another Google
database product,
when would it make sense for
them to look at switching,
and why would it make
sense for them to switch?
MARK MANDEL: So that was
a great question, AJ.
Francesc, I know
you found, actually,
a really nice answer on
Quora that we can link to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I searched on Google.
What's the difference between
Google Cloud Spanner and Cloud
SQL?
And I found a question
on Quora with the title,
what's the difference between
Google Cloud Spanner and Cloud
SQL?
MARK MANDEL: How fortuitous.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is a very good answer.
So we'll definitely link to it.
I'm going to try to say
the name of the person that
wrote the answer.
It's [? Zanco Houdicjeck. ?]
MARK MANDEL: That
seems good to me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
[? Houdicjheck, ?] I think.
MARK MANDEL: Sure, sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If someone
knows how to pronounce--
I'd say that probably this
is some Slavic language.
If anyone knows how
to pronounce it,
I'd love to be
corrected about this.
[? Zanco ?] says
the main difference
is that Spanner is horizontally
scalable and Cloud SQL is not.
What does that actually mean?
What it means is that Cloud
SQL is vertically scalable,
which means that if your server
is getting too small for you,
you can make that server bigger.
So you can add disk, you can
add memory, you can add CPUs,
but you cannot
really add servers.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, so once
you hit that vertical limit,
you're stuck.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
The whole thing is that
if you want more servers,
you could actually do it.
But then you start
basically paying
for the extra cost
of those SQL servers
connecting to each other.
And it doesn't scale that well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you
could do read replicas.
But you, obviously,
doing write replicas--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
for read replicas-- yeah,
read replicas, that works.
For write replicas, it
doesn't really work.
Now, at Spanner, it
allows you to do this.
Basically, for every
note that you add,
you get extra throughput.
So you get extra
memory, extra CPUs,
extra everything, but
also, extra throughput,
which is what you
really care about--
extra throughput both
for reads and writes.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
with that, basically,
if you have a cluster
of [INAUDIBLE] notes,
and at some point
you're like, oh,
we're very close
to the capacity--
I want to scale this
up-- you just add a note.
That's it.
You don't need to do anything
extra, which is really cool.
Now, you need to take into
account that, yes, it allows
you-- so Spanner allows
you to basically do
the same cool things
that you can do
with SQL for select statements.
So when you're reading, you
can do pretty much the same.
And when you're
writing too though,
the semantics are
slightly different.
You cannot use SQL, for
now at least, to write.
In Spanner, you're going to need
to use the gRPC or REST APIs.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but
those are idiomatic APIs
for each language that use it.
So it's not like you're
writing an insert,
like command rather than
writing an insert statement.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so basically
the thing to take
into account is
that if you have something
brewing with Cloud SQL,
and you want to
migrate to Spanner--
MARK MANDEL: There's
a bit of work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --you may need
to change that a little bit,
not for the reads.
For the writes, you
may need to change it--
so something to
take into account.
MARK MANDEL: Now,
it's also worth
noting Cloud Spanner is
going to be a bit more
expensive than Cloud SQL.
So I figure it almost
comes down to how much
data do you expect to have,
or how much data do you have,
and what sort of read and
write throughput do you need?
If maybe you have--
I don't know-- 100,000
records or so, maybe you
keep that all in Cloud SQL.
If you start getting into
millions or billions,
and you need to be able
to have access to those,
and interact with them
in a transactional way,
in a high read/write
throughput way, then maybe then
that's when you start looking
at something like spanner.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, yeah, just
to give you an idea of node per
hour cost, it's $0.90,
which is not that much.
But again, it can go up to
$600 or something like that,
I think, per month.
So Cloud SQL, you
can have definitely
way, way cheaper than that.
Now, the difference
is that at some point,
you cannot make
Cloud SQL go faster.
Spanner, you can always
make it go faster.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
probably not going
to move my personal
WordPress site to Spanner.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: My
personal web page
is very happily on
data store running
on App Engine standard,
which means that I'm not
paying for anything.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep,
so that's pretty nice.
But yeah.
If you have something way
bigger than my personal web
page, which is basically every
single project every created,
you may want to use
something like this.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So now things have
calmed down a little.
But I think you're jetsetting
off, at least in a few weeks?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
I'm actually staying around
San Francisco for a little
bit, which it's always exciting
because now we
have nice weather.
Hey, people from New York.
How's it going?
But afterwards, my
next trip is going
to be-- for April
15 and 16, I will be
in GopherCon China in Shanghai.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
very excited about trying
to speak in Mandarin there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, what about you?
MARK MANDEL: So
I am also staying
in San Francisco
for a few weeks,
but then I will be
off to Vancouver.
I'll be doing a little
meetup, Polyglot Vancouver.
I'll be there presenting
on gRPC and Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Now that you mentioned
gRPC, we should definitely
talk about this.
So this is coming out on
3/15, which is pie plus one.
Yesterday was pie
day, and we released
a demo for pie
day, which is a pie
API, because it sounds cool.
And it's a gRPC, plus
REST API, with web socket,
and all that stuff.
So you can basically build
visualizations on top of it.
If you want to
learn more about it,
you should go check it
out on pie dot delivery.
It's totally a top level domain.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I didn't know.
But yeah, pie dot delivery.
And you're going to
see a bunch of demos.
You can visualize
pie, and play pie.
So you can actually
see the music.
But also, you're going
to see documentation,
how to use the API.
And all of this is powered,
Google Cloud platform,
with Cloud Endpoints, And
container engine, and Go.
MARK MANDEL: And gRPC?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And gRPC, and Go.
MARK MANDEL: And you
helped build it, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
That's why it's Go.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
That's super cool.
Actually, I was playing
with that earlier today,
and it's very, very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so that could
have been a cool
thing of the week,
except we forgot about it.
So there you go.
MARK MANDEL: There we go,
extra cool thing of the week.
Yeah, cool.
So yeah.
After I'm in Vancouver
for a Polyglot meetup,
I'm going to be the East Coast
Game Developers Conference.
And then after that,
I'll be at Vector.
That will be from the 16th
of April and the 21st,
respectively.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice,
sounds lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Francesc, it's been
a harrowing few weeks,
but I'm so glad to be back in
this voice overbooth with you.
Thank you for taking
the time once again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you,
again, for taking the time.
And thank you all for
listening to this episode.
And to every single person
that was there at Next,
thank you so much for
coming and saying hi.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]